à venir sur le plafond de la zone de largage, vous faites
n'importe quoi de ensoleillé samedi soir, eh bien, tous
les gars de mon quatuor de barbier sont
morts, donc non, pas vraiment, vous savez si vous
demandez à Kristen de sortir des statistiques, vous
diriez probablement oui, c'est pourquoi ne demandez pas
trop timide  ou trop effrayé faire occupé
voir où cela nuit tu sais
non il n'était pas
le bouclier commun pour protéger les gens
capitaine pour construire un monde meilleur
signifie parfois abattre tout
celui qui fait des ennemis
êtes-vous prêt pour que le monde vous voie
comme vous êtes vraiment  êtes-vous regarder par la
fenêtre vous savez comment le jeu fonctionne
guerre de désordre
tout ce qu'il faut c'est une étape
nous neutraliserons beaucoup de menaces
avant même qu'elles ne se produisent
Je pensais que la punition venait généralement
après que le bouclier du crime ait pris le monde
car il n'est pas comme nous  j'aimerais que ce soit ce
n'est pas la liberté c'est la peur
tu dois garder les deux yeux ouverts avant de
commencer est-ce que quelqu'un veut sortir
ton travail a été un cadeau pour l'humanité
tu as façonné le siècle
j'ai besoin que tu fasses  une fois de
plus je me prépare  il est temps que
tu